so you have six months and you want to
learn as much about computational
Neuroscience as possible how to do it
and where to get started in today's
video I really want to give you three
tips to learn computational Neuroscience
a little bit faster or to get started
and give you some resources so hi I'm
Charlotte Professor a third year PhD
student in computational neuroscience
and a lot of you have asked me in the
comments how do I get started with
computational Neuroscience how do I
learn it a little bit faster and I have
made two tutorials on where to find
resources and books Etc on learning
computational Neuroscience but today I
want to talk a little bit about the
mindset of programming and also
computational neuroscience and how to
get better at that such that you may
increase your learning speed for
computational Neuroscience overall so
the first thing I want to talk about a
little bit is the mindset shift so
already in the sentence how do I learn
computational Neuroscience faster I
think there's a tiny problem and that's
the concept of learning so I've think
when you want to learn something you're
really in this mindset of a student and
I think a lot of you are probably
students so that's where that comes from
but computational Neuroscience is still
in its infancy the field hasn't started
for that long so the things that are
being discovered follow each other up so
fast that the things that were maybe
common knowledge five years ago could be
proven wrong today and I think that's a
major shift you have to make if you want
to start in a field of computational
Neuroscience so instead of the word
learning I would use the word creating
so how can I create computational
Neuroscience faster and that's because
probably if you have any type of skill
and you start in the field right now you
could actually add quite tremendously
because the field is so young so instead
of looking at theoretical textbooks then
I would actually look at papers that
were published this year and for example
you can use the website scopus and just
list the Articles from the highest cited
rate to the lowest and if you kind of go
through those or look at some reviews in
computational neuroscience will get a
sense of what the field is currently
looking for or where the general
consensus currently is within the field
and the second thing I want to talk
about is leaning into your strengths so
a lot of videos that I've made as well
are emphasizing the ability to program
so if you want to do computational
Neuroscience you have to be quite a good
programmer but something that I've seen
in the comments is that people really go
for programming but the thing you have
to consider that if you want to be the
best at computational Neuroscience or
you want to get really good at it and
your only skill is programming you need
to be a damn good programmer to really
stand out and that's because within the
computational Neuroscience fair but also
within the AI sir there are a lot of
people that are trained as programmers
from the start so I've met a lot of PhD
students and postdocs that are amazing
programmers but the thing is if you're
starting programming a little bit at a
later age the chances of you becoming as
good as those programs are quite slim
unless you spend like eight hours a day
programming so instead of following the
path of becoming the best programmer and
in that way standing out with your
skills I would actually lean into the
skills that you already have so for
example if you are already doing a
bachelor right now in for example
biology psychology or physics I would
lean more on those skills so something
that I've noticed is if you're in the
top 25 percent of one of these skills
and you're a really good programmer
these combined skills actually make you
pretty unique within the sphere of
computational Neuroscience so to give
you an example like my background is in
physics and I would say I'm pretty good
at mathematics so I may not be the best
programmer but within the realm that I
operate I am quite fast at solving
mathematical equations or understanding
certain physics Concepts and that
together combined with my decent
programming skills give me a good skill
set to be able to create new work in
computational Neuroscience so I would
advise you to really start thinking
about what unique skills you have that
you can bring on top of your programming
skills to create some new work in
computational neuroscience and one way
that I really like to dive into this
mindset is by using this board from Miro
that I'm gonna show you right now so
within mirror you have these different
types of boards to get conversations
going and all these things but one that
I really like is this personas board and
the personas board is usually used to
create a character of a client for
example that you want but I find it also
pretty good to understand your own
motivations and mindset so for example I
created a Persona board for myself and
the first step what you do is you look
at your own action actions motivations
and pains and I think by understanding
this you can kind of see where your
strengths are as well so the first step
is to fill in what you do every day so
for me I have to research for my thesis
every day and write code and think and
teach and then why I do it so my main
motivation for doing science actually is
to learn as much as possible but also to
teach as much as possible I enjoy both
of these facets of Science and combining
them in my PhD is really nice so my
strengths for me that's really
mathematics and programming I think I'm
quite good at both of them not the best
but quite good and I think it's also
good to consider what is stopping you so
for me definitely the reason why I'm not
creating as much science as I could be
is probably energy I don't have all the
energy in the world and also time I like
to spend my time on other things as well
so what convinces me these are your
values and for me their wisdom and
creativity I think usually when I decide
to Endeavor on certain projects or I
want to do something I usually pick if
this is following the value of wisdom or
the value of creativity and I do think
these are actually intertwined if you
really think about it what or who
informs me so these are the people
within your around that kind of help and
support the goals that you want to reach
so for me that's definitely my professor
and my fellow PhD students then where am
I right now so I'm usually where are you
every day in time so I'm usually in the
office or in a train lately and what's
my day today so according teaching
friends family dance and yoga so yeah
this is just an example of how I filled
in this board and you don't have to use
this for it you can also use pen and
paper but really thinking about your
strengths how you live your day-to-day
life who is helping you who guides you
along I think is a really good way to
see and pinpoint where weaknesses are in
your day and perhaps change them such
that you can learn everything you want
to a little bit faster then the first
tip I want to give you so I've now
talked about like leaning into your
strengths and probably you're wondering
but what if I have a lot of gaps in my
Neuroscience knowledge for example or my
psychology knowledge or my mathematics
knowledge and that's where I would try
to surround you Yourself by experts so
for example within my lab there are
people from many different backgrounds
and I think most of us are an expert at
a certain part in computational
Neuroscience but I don't think all of us
are actually really good at everything
and something that I've noticed is that
students that really Thrive as a PhD are
actually pretty good at finding people
that can help them answer certain
questions so for example right now we're
starting on a project on cognitive
variables and I don't know that much
about cognition I don't know exactly how
these tests are measured or why the
tests were set up the way they are and
of course I could read everything about
it and become an expert on cognition or
I could just ask someone that's already
an aspect expert to spend about an hour
of their time with me and perhaps I buy
them a coffee or something and teach me
everything they know and you will notice
that the knowledge you have is not only
the knowledge you have as an individual
but kind of the knowledge of your
community at that point and if you're of
course in a situation that you cannot
use connect with a lot of people it's
also possible to find for example people
online that can help you find this
knowledge so I also created a website
where I try to give tips on
computational Neuroscience every week
and help you learn a few of the basic
skills but of course you can also find
people that you really like or
professors on Twitter and follow them
and read their papers and I think this
way you get this community knowledge
that hopefully helps you learn these
type of things a lot faster so yeah
these were three tips I have for
changing your mindset around learning
computational Neuroscience I hope they
helped a little bit if you have any
other questions I would love to answer
them so please put them down in the
comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye